Notebook Alm just changed the game.
Custom infographics are live right now.
As you can see, this was just announced
a few hours ago. And notebook just made
every designer very nervous. This
Google's free AI tool just dropped
something changes content creation
forever. You can now take any document,
any PDF, any notes you have and turn it
into a stunning professional infographic
that's custom design. This is not like
some generic style. You can actually add
custom designs inside the infographic
session as you can see right here. So
you can choose your style. Um, one click
and you are good to go on that. And you
see all these different styles have been
added. So there's 10 preset options and
the ability to create [music] your own.
Plus you can choose from like editorial
play all sorts of cool stuff as you can
see. And that's basically how it works.
So it's a brand new example. You can
also guide the infographic on what you
want to focus on the style that you want
to set up. And then you can customize
this infographic much. So you pick the
one that fits your brand or build your
own custom style from scratch. one click
and this is completely free to use. So
this isn't just a cool feature. This is
something that really help you automate
a lot of designs, a lot of social media
content and we'll show you exactly how
to automate sales. Okay, so you can once
you if starting from scratch, you never
used notebook, let me show you how to
get this set up from scratch, right? So
what you're going to do is you're going
to go to create a new notebook here.
Basically these notebooks are like
different notebooks [music] of research
that you can insert into sort of AI
trained version of that particular
topic. Right? So let's say for example
we wanted to create a notebook on open
core and then we want to create some
custom infographics. So we can type in
open core over here and then we can
start [music] doing the research to pull
in relevant websites to that topic. What
that's going to do is just go off
automate the research [music] for us. We
can also do research but we're just
going to focus on past research and then
that can research the web find topics
for us [music] and we can just import
them into node. What does that mean? It
means you can train the AI in a custom
way on exactly the topic you want. So it
becomes a topic specialist on that
particular um
AI update for example or whatever you're
trying to research here. Now, once
you've done that, it's going to pull all
of these into the notebook as you can
see. And then you're going to get
something that looks like this. Right
now, on the left hand side, you've got
all your research. In the middle, you've
got the notebook that you can ask
questions to and that sort of thing. And
then on the right hand side, you can
begin to generate the graphics you want.
Now, you can choose between these
different styles here. As you can see,
you can select portrait, square, or
landscape. You can select which language
you want to use and then
you can describe the infographic you
want to create. So and then once it's
generated you're going to get an
infographic back. So let's test this
out. We actually got an example
infographic over here that we've created
previously. So this is about open core
and how it works etc. um the whole
project and it was just automated in one
click. Now if you want to generate
something like that, you can open up
here and we could put like okay um 10
core use cases of open core inside this
example and you can choose the level of
detail you want. You can have concise,
standard or detailed say okay 10 core
use open core and then you can choose
what style you want in terms of the
infographic layout right so let's say
for example we want to create something
that looks kind of this cool sketch note
we want to stick to English and let's
say for example portrait work well on X
and that's what we generate this for
then we could hit generate like so it'll
begin to create this infographic here on
the right hand side you can also
generate audio views video views slide
decks my mouse reports flash quizzes
data tables as well as infographics and
you can also generate multiple
infographics at the same time. So here
we take 50 tips for using
and we can do the same method and we can
also auto select. So if you don't want
to choose your own custom style just go
with the auto select option and then
you're good to go and we can change that
to detailed because we're going to add
more information like this graphic.
Obviously 50 tips is a lot to to put in
and we're going to select portrait again
for that. And now it's going to generate
two different infographics at the same
time. And again, this is a free tool
that you can use for doing. Now, if we
open up, this is this is where it gets
interesting actually. So,
if we go to a tool called anti-gravity,
which is kind of like a local vibe
coding tool, we can actually use
anti-gravity with notebook and then
insert these infographics into our
projects, right? So, how do you do that?
Well, here's an example. So what we
actually did here is we connected an MCP
server which is basically just a fancy
way of saying connecting notebook for
example to anti-gravity and then you can
create infographics and put those
infographics inside any sort of websites
and landing pages you're coding out with
antigraphy locally. You can see an
example here. We said use notebook leng
to generate a notebook about law and
then it used the MCP tool and it created
a notebook about openclaw as you can see
right here. Right? So this whole
notebook was created with anti-gravity.
So if we go inside anti-gravity and
we're like okay um create a call
infographic
on notebook anti-gravity. It will then
use the MCP tool and connect
anti-gravity to notebook and then with
the infographics that you generate you
can actually use that inside the
projects on the website wherever you
want to create it. So you can see it
working right there. Now if we go back
to open core you can see that we've got
the 10 ways to use open core infographic
ready to go and how easy was that? It
shows all the different use cases. The
text is super nice. It was completely
automated. We can download this as well.
So if we click on save image as we've
now got that image ready to go and you
can share that on social media or you
can talk people through it in a
presentation or whatever you want to do
right um and so that's basically the
custom infographic update works really
well ready to go pretty simple and easy
to set up um you can connect it to
anti-gravity as well if you're wondering
like how do you use anti-gravity with
notebook what you do is just copy the
notebook lm mcp details here the github
project so this is an open source free
extension and then you can inst that
directly into antiquity or any other
tool that you wanted to connect it with.
I think you could probably even do that
inside openclaw if you wanted to.
Although I would be careful with
integrating um open claw with any of
Google's technologies. But that's
basically how it works. And then you can
see we've got the infographic
generating. So this was automated fully
by anti-gravity and antigraphy actually
automated and created the infographic
just so you can link the two systems
together. Pretty amazing to talk. That's
basically it.
for the new update. Just to recap what
notebook does so it couldn't do before.
When you generate an infographic, you
can now get a visual style selector.
These are the options rolling out. You
got auto select, editorial, blah blah
blah. And you can have your own um
ability to create your own custom style.
This means you're no longer stuck with
generic instantly recognizable
infographics everyone can spot. You can
match your style to your brand, your
audience, your niche, your voice. And
also for you, if you're running a
business, every time you create content
that looks different, looks beautiful,
and looks like it took the designer 3
hours to make, but it actually took 3
minutes, you went be more credible. Your
content get shared more, you attract
more customers. Um, we actually got a
30-day plan really leveraging this with
dayby-day prompts. As you can see inside
the video notes today, this is all
inside the AI prof link in the comments
description. We have 100 prompts test as
well. So if you're using the custom
style section for infographics for 100
prompts you get out with this as you can
see. So feel free to get that link in
the comments description. We have the
4hour course on how to use notebook as
well as you can see and that's updated
daily inside community. So for example
we have a full sixhour course on how to
use open claw. We have new guides today
on like a lama pi the new notebook
update open claw and how to use it for
free and also the new update from 3.5
which is add new cool stuff about what's
working and how to use it inside the AI
profering that's available link in the
comment description or go to a
profboarding.com now inside this
community we have 2500 people so you can
post questions inside the community get
help get support whenever you need we
have live coaching inside the calendar
here so you can jump on video calls when
you need to visit maps you can meet
people in your local area. And then
inside the classroom too, you can see
that for example, we guide you from
beginner to expert in just 5 weeks on AI
automation. You'll learn how to build
your first AI agent in under five
minutes. Additionally, you'll get
training on my best playbooks. So, for
example, how I automate newsletters,
X shorts, Instagram, AI, avatar videos,
etc. And then you can find the daily
updates right here too. The agency
course, you can learn how to get more
agency clients right here. Then
if you want to learn how to rank number
one with AICO, you've got that section
there.
And also with YouTube, you can learn how
to grow a YouTube channel with AI using
this road map. So that's all inside the
AI profit boarding link in the comments
description. Thanks for watching. Let's
see what we got in the questions here.
Can you show how to connect AI Studio to
anti-gravity? I think that features
coming soon, but it's still in beta.
And feels asks, "How do I see credits
between max and browsion?" Yeah, so I'm
not 100% certain. I'm not an expert on,
you know, how to manage credits, but I
think you get like 10,000 credits a
month with Flexi. And then depending on
which use, whether that's the computer
or whether that's the main version of
Flexi, you just check in your settings
and find it. So, thanks for watching.
See you on the next one. This cover.